so what did Demario Jackson think of the
controversial bachelor in paradise
premiere let's find out
it's the moment on bachelor in paradise
we've been waiting for but really didn't
happen I'm talking about what went down
between Korean and Demario now if you
watched last night's premiere then you
know there wasn't much clarity on that
whole entire situation
thanks for the two-hour tease ABC but
thankfully we have the man at the center
of it all
jamario Jackson and as our lauren zima
found out no one is more interested in
showing the tale of the tape than this
guy how do you feel about the way that
things with you and Corinne were
ultimately portrayed I'm just excited
you know I can breathe you know being
the villain being the bad guy being the
you know the you know the rapist you
know being the guy who took advantage of
this extremely drunk girl and then it
wasn't
well you had told me you'd said roll the
tape I want them to roll the tape do you
feel they rolled enough of the tape I
feel like they rolled enough of the tape
because it you know it you can't show
too much because that's going to
disrespect both you know Kareem and I
just and I just feel like that it just
so be like the like the best or the
classiest thing to do they showed enough
you know they showed us interacting
prior you know they showed us in the
pool they showed us swimming around
okay so Demario was actually pleased
with how the show addressed the scandal
in fact he says he feels like LeBron
when you won his first title but as you
guys know Demario and Corinth time on
paradise was cut short they never
returned but all were cleared of any
misconduct allegations now his message
for Corinne I love you and I'm here for
you there's plenty more where that came
from
tonight on ET and ET online but moving
on to kim kardashian the beauty boss is
getting some flack over her contour kits
specifically from makeup artist and
youtuber Jeffrey star it all started
when Kim gave fans a preview of some of
her new products and Jeffrey called out
the way Kim was showing off the palette
calling her swatches rough and they look
like chalk apparently the comments about
her swatching gave her a pimple folks
I was a huge I know in comment but I
also watch out I stress Amina I know I
didn't know how to watch it well Kim's
fans of course went after Jeffery but
she stepped back in and thanked him for
his criticism while getting her chest
highlighted thank you I welcome honest
you know comments about my products and
because of it i'm swatching better now
so so everyone get off his ass and let's
not be so negative we're all in this
together there's room for all of us love
you Jeffrey well that has got to be one
of the most short-lived social media few
ever got good things because there's so
much drama on daily dating today but
let's get into John Mayer now who knew
that Mayer was such a sensitive soul but
39 year old singer recently said his new
song never on the day you leave is about
an ex and that it makes him so sad that
he can't play it live
I repeat so sad he can't perform it live
but also it's entirely possible that
this sad song is about Mayer's ex Katy
Perry the evidence
check out these lyrics love grows in the
time it's been since you last heard her
scene she'll cut her hair and move
somewhere she don't owe you anything
well hello Katy not only scenes but she
famously cut her hair around the time
mayor wrote this song now listen to him
tell serious ex and the highway host
buzz Brainerd about the lines that make
him super emotional she'll fight for you
like hell and force herself to like some
other man that's what women do they show
up a hundred percent there is a time
they are there a hundred percent with
everything and then at some point for
whatever reason not making a judgement
you or someone else says nah and what
they force themselves to do to get over
you is so transformative for good and
bad you will never see that whole person
again now if it is Katy that he's
talking about then presumably the other
man is Orlando Bloom who by the way his
body sincerely
is a wonderland now Katie was recently
spotted with bloom at Ed Sheeran's
concert but the jury is still out on
them so there's always a chance for
reconciliation with John Mayer her
number one in bed her words not mine are
you guys that is it for today tonight I
am at the AGT live shows talking with
all the judges and hosts Tyra Banks will
have all of that for you guys tomorrow
on the daily Demi so be sure to hit
subscribe and check out ET online for
all the latest in entertainment news are
you guys I'm going to shimmy my way out
of here goodbye thank you